is a Barry Trammell they're absolutely
all the columnist for The Oklahoman he
joins us now Barry thanks for joining us
how are you alright what did you see
last night how do you explain coming
back from 25 down oh I think I think the
Thunder got the fried wounded a little
bit because they'd played so poorly in
Salt Lake and then played so poorly for
28 minutes last night that a lot of
people were questioning you know all
kinds of things including their
character and I think they realized it
and they sort of woke up and you know
they got some help I mean Rudy Gobert
gets in foul trouble you chose a
different team but they started playing
with desperation and that's what you got
to do in the playoffs helps if you start
that way in the first quarter but they
did it in the third quarter last night
how frustrating is this team i watch
pretty frustrating because you saw how
good they can be but you've also seen
them just sort of go up and down all
year lose a bunch of games lost two to
Dallas lose to the Nets you know just
endless games like that but you know
you've also seen them take it to the
Warriors take it to the Rockets take it
to the Raptors and last night they took
it to the Jazz when their season was on
the brink did you have a column written
at halftime Barry I was deciding between
two terms they were doornail dead that's
an old an old term from my childhood I
don't know where it came from but but
also I was going to quote The Wizard of
Oz they weren't they weren't just merely
dead they were really sincerely dead but
you know I had to throw that all that
away by the time Westbrook scored his 20
points in the third quarter so ya had to
start over if the Thunder don't advance
dot-dot-dot
not a questions you know I think Billy
Donovan's futures up in the air I think
the Thunder like Singh but they would
sacrifice him if they had to if they
don't advance it's more likely than ever
that Paul George leaves now frankly he
may be out the door anyway but it's you
know there was the way they were playing
up until that third quarter last night
they were given Paul George no reason to
stay you know for most of this year you
could say you know his best basketball
option might be to bless he just wants
to go join a super team might be to to
stay in Oklahoma City and play with
Steven Adams and Russell Westbrook there
was not much of a case for that until
last night in these playoffs
what about Carmel most future Carmelo is
a shell of himself we've had a debate
this week on whether his his decline was
gradual and we just playing in New York
nobody ever watched him play which is
sort of funny to say but or did he just
fall off the cliff this offseason he
really doesn't have much left in terms
of explosion or athletic ability he's
not an eight million dollar a year play
or much less a twenty-eight million
dollar a year player so you know best
thing for the Thunder is if he would
decline his option I assume his
accountant it's not gonna let him do
that so you know I don't know what we
don't know what's going to happen but
the best thing for the Thunder is if he
decided he wanted to go play somewhere
else
he's Barry Trammell the columnist for
The Oklahoman joining us Dan Patrick
show I know you've written about Baker
Mayfield good and bad if if a team went
to you and said what do you think of
Baker Mayfield what would you tell that
NFL team about it than I do but if you
think a six-foot quarterback can survive
well then let me promise you he will
he's an he's an uncanny passer just
unbelievable accuracy
he's a gamer he's a fabulous quarterback
but there's stuff you're gonna have to
live with off the field he wants to be a
celebrity there's not any question about
that he does not want to be like Manning
he wants to be Joe Namath
so as long as you go into that with your
eyes wide open you know you're gonna be
okay but if you think you're getting Eli
Manning you're going to be sadly
mistaken if you were the Cleveland
Browns would you take him if I was
between Browns I wouldn't take any
quarterback I mean the NFL is just rife
with with quarterback mistakes if you
got a bad roster hacks you got a good
roster I'd take somebody high that I
knew could play I wouldn't take a gamble
on anybody and it sounds like all of
these guys have a little bit of mystery
about him I wouldn't pick take it one or
four on a guy I wasn't completely sure
good play Barry thank you get some sleep
and you know have fun with this next
game here okay thanks guys all right
it's very Trammell columnist for the
Oklahoma for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]